why did you come to drangleic it wasn't
to sit the throne and you knew nothing
about linking a fire you didn't come
here to become the next monarch nor did
you come here to unite the Crown's of
past Kings we came here because of what
we lost memories long ago of things that
were important to us a woman a child the
home these represent a life that we no
longer have once cursed you lose
everything no one seems to know the
origins of this curse but no one seems
to particularly care about it either all
they care about is a cure and that's
where drangleic comes in because
drangleic is a kingdom rumored by many
characters within it to have this cure
as we travel through drangleic we become
so embroiled with the stories of the
people we meet and the land we explore
that most people actually forget why
they're there did you figure because if
you did that's rather the point you
forget just like your character did all
this talk of kings and queens and
Thrones and whatnot it's enough to
confuse anyone into forgetting but I'm
reminding you why you're here
because of what happens once you've
completed the dlc and what happens once
you've gathered the crown of every king
when you return to vendrick a short
cinematic place where he restores the
power of the crowns you might not have
noticed this but while wearing a crown
from this point onwards you're
completely immune to the effects of the
curse simply put you'll no longer hollow
upon death your body will not decay your
mind will not fade from a purely selfish
point of view you have essentially found
a way to deflect the undead curse but
there's a really important distinction
you have to make it wearing the crowns
isn't a cure for the curse it's
treatment it helps you with the symptoms
but it's not a solution a cure for the
curse means to become truly human to
live out a lifespan and die that's what
it means to be human you know why we
haven't cured our curse yet it's because
our character keeps respawning when he
dies the developer kind of needs this
gameplay mechanic so don't expect to get
cured anytime soon to be Undead
to be undying and as you died over and
over again you forget what it is to be
human this process is called Halloween
and it continues until you become
completely Hollow and just to be clear
that's hollow with a capital H because
once you become completely hollow you
can never attain your humanity again
Undead are called faithless by
everything in the game because they're
all destined to go Hollow
eventually no other fate is allowed to
them but you're different are you the
next monarch or merely a pawn of fate
I believe all undead are pawns of fate
because they're destined to Hollow The
Herald makes this distinction between
the next monarch and pawns of fate
precisely because whoever is a true king
does not Hollow
whoever unites the four crowns of Lords
long past will still be undead but now
they can cast off the shackles of fate
and create a future that doesn't end in
you turning into beef jerky and you
might be thinking great this is a
blessing I can live forever and not feel
the effects of hollowing but think about
how this would play out in reality
imagine being immune to the curse in a
world filled with cursed people in true
Dark Souls fashion you've been given a
solution that involves watching everyone
around you and everyone you love fade
into insanity you're the one sane person
in a dying world you alone have found
the one thing that all cursed undead in
drangleic are craving think about Luka
teal who ends her journey just a few
short steps from her brother
a woman who fully expects to go hollow
Luka teal is just one of many humans who
came to drangleic precisely because they
heard there was a cure here and they
were right though the rumors made it
sound way better than it was there is a
way to avoid hollowing in drangleic and
we've found it but the tragedy is it's
not a cure and it only helps one person
this highlights how little we know about
the curse the cycles of kingdoms and the
nature of light and dark before we found
the crowns our motivation was internal
we wanted to stop hollowing we
wanted to stop losing memories of loved
ones or things we cared about and that's
why we came here but now that we found
the crowns don't you feel like all of a
sudden our motivation is focused
externally we're forced to seek answers
from the world itself why does the curse
exist why is history repeating itself
why a katana is still so overpowered now
that we have the crowns we finally have
the power to fight the undead curse
indefinitely
and in my opinion anything in the series
from this point onwards should revolve
around that singular fact find the
crowns and your own answers there are
four Lords in Dark Souls one who found
four great souls of power within the
first flame neato Guin the witch of
izalith and the furtive pygmy each of
their souls are found within dark souls2
as well
they're called the souls of the
ineffable too extreme to be described
each of them says in their description
that they continue to exert influence
over the land even though they're just
remnants of once great Souls the key
phrase is exerts influence over the land
these souls don't just inhabit the
bodies of certain beings they do but
just like the pale Drake soul infests
the writhing ruin of sand and spiders I
believe that the other Souls become a
part of the land itself
what if long ago a chosen Undead carved
all the souls from these beings and put
them in a lured vessel created to hold
Souls what if this lured vessel broke
and the souls no longer had a vessel to
hold them it's just speculation but it
could be true the king unites his
kingdom and the crown is his symbol I
believe the Crown's hold the strength of
lords from Dark Souls 1 a power carried
into the kingdom's these Kings inhabit
and since the crown is a symbol of a
kingdom it could hold their power the
sunken crown would contain NATO's power
this king ruled far underground in a
kingdom lost to toxicity it lies behind
the rotten who is an amalgamation of
humanoid things just like nito is an
amalgamation of skeletons it has his
characteristics the iron crown would
contain Gwynn's power this Iron King
arrogant with his strength built a
kingdom of fire we kill the iron King
himself who holds a part of Gwyn soul
and the ivory crown would contain the
witch's power it's from a kingdom that
fought and protected and possibly
created a powerful flame of chaos it's
directly related to the lost sinner who
real it a flame of her own and lastly
vendrick ruled the kingdom of men and he
turned Hollow himself he and his kingdom
seemed directly related to the dark soul
of humanity by comparison the previous
Kings are nowhere to be found
so maybe they weren't cursed or maybe
they weren't human though I guess they
could be you could argue that all
kingdoms had humans within them but it
is interesting to note that there are
more references to the undead curse in
vendrick's Kingdom as well as his
kingdom only containing human sized
humans where the other ones contain
taller humanoid creatures I don't know
what to call them it's always best to
ignore size in Dark Souls law it seems
to be an indication of power more than
anything else in this universe but
bottom line is there are more links to
humans in vendrick's Kingdom which means
he's more closely related to the pygmy
which means he's more closely related to
the dark soul and humanity so the
Crown's could hold the strength of the
four Lords who held shards of the first
flame now a lot of the assumptions I'm
going to make do rely on this fact but I
do believe that what we've essentially
done is inherit the power of the first
flame there are a few other things to
back this up I mean nashandra was after
the first flame after all if you proceed
nashandra will come after you knowing
that you will take the throne and Link
the fire she covets the first flame and
the great soul put nashandra to rest
she and her sisters were driven to
collect all of the crowns they went into
each kingdom and drove their Kings to
ruin if they had any united goal any
singular purpose that would drive them
to go into conquer kingdoms it would be
to take these crowns I think this also
explains the description on vendrick
soul the king was wasted away a shadow
of his former self
but he still held something dear we
originally thought that he was referring
to the ring he has that unlocks his
kingdom but if it's dear to him it could
well have been his crown he did lock it
away as well he wasn't just hiding the
throne away from nashandra the crown is
really important too it holds a faint
heat within it and the heat could be a
clue to it being a fragment of the power
of the first flame I'd say we need
vendrick's blessing to realize this
power because vendrick is essentially
passing his monarchy over to us long ago
he conquered the four great ones and
built a Kingdom upon their souls uniting
the first flame so now it's time for us
to ascend to his rule nashandra was
forced to wait for vendrick to pass away
as he hid from her when we kill vendrick
she tells us drangleic is no longer but
by going into vendrick's memory by going
back in time and taking the monarchy
from him we can alter the timeline he
can pass this monarchy to us inherit
fire and harness the dark such is the
calling of a true leader we are
inheriting the fire the crowns are that
fire together they could well be a
representation of the great soul or the
first flame once we've inherited this
fire we no longer Hollow so we can
harness the dark the power to never die
so we have all this what now what's our
purpose now seek strength the rest will
follow
there is still more we have to do it's
not over yet to succeed we must throw
off the dark but is such a thing even
possible shadow is not cast but born of
fire and the brighter the flame the
deeper the shadow all this makes me
think that vendrick may once have been
in our position he might have been
unable to die searching for a cure it
seems like he found answers but it's
definitely true that they weren't the
ones he was hoping for with fire they
say a true king can harness the curse a
lie but I knew no better one day fire
will fade and dark will become a curse
the opening cutscene of Dark Souls also
says but soon the flames will fade and
only dark will remain all this
information doesn't bode well for us a
tonal darkness seems to be that one
conclusion most characters with more
knowledge than us come to that's not
good men will be free from death left a
wonder eternally to wander eternally and
to be free from death that is
essentially to be Hollow
in fact some argue that this is the
original state of all humanoid beings
before the first flame you know what you
see on screen that seems to be what all
humanoid creatures were created from and
I'd go as far as to say as they are
hollows they're empty vessels and when
they found souls within the first flame
they became different things they became
unique beings so some of these beings
found four powerful souls in the first
flame and they took these souls for
themselves so there was Gwyn there was
the which there was neato but the most
important one to us was the furtive
pygmy he or she was the holder of the
Dark Soul that creature gave humanity
fragments to the hollows and created
humans he broke his soul which we know
people can do he broke his soul into
little bits and he gave everyone a sharp
a shard of humanity essentially he
created humanity for vendrick to say
that men will be free from death is to
say that they will lose their humanity
he's saying we will no longer die we
will revert to this hollow state and we
will wander eternally just like you see
in this cutscene dark will again be ours
and in our crew shape we can bury the
false legends of your only he's saying
that we can only escape the cycle by
embracing darkness instead of
continually relighting the first flame
and continually starting that cycle over
again only is this our own in Chive
eventually nashandra or some other
element of dark might win and bring the
kingdom to darkness seek strength the
rest will follow
a king sees what he chooses to see and
just like in Dark Souls 1 do we embrace
dark and allow the Queens to win or do
we fight it to relight the first flame
the fire can give comfort but it can
burn like the flame of chaos dead just
so dark can represent hatred and lust
for power but there are examples of
tranquility and forgiveness within it so
are you fighting against a side or are
you fighting to show that humanity can
be the best of both so that pretty much
does it for my speculation I mean I
really want to end on this one final
note something doesn't feel right with
the way the DLC was ended now granted
it's not like from to do a huge dramatic
ending that explains everything
but even so it makes little sense from a
gameplay perspective why give players
power over Halloween if you're not
giving them anything else to fight from
software often makes their point through
gameplay and from a gameplay perspective
this ending was lacking we were all
hoping for that huge fight with Manus or
the discovery that channel odd was our
queen some twist you know speaking of
which I want to talk about channel so
put your conspiracy hats on because
alsanna
Alana nashandra nerd alia all these
queens have the nut sound in their name
including Shannon a lot I'm not saying
she's our queen guys but come on she's
totally a queen the connections escape
happening when you also consider that
else anna says my sisters are as a thick
dark we're lost for souls insatiable
this kind of makes you think oh [ __ ]
I've been giving the Emerald Herald my
souls for the whole game anyway that's
enough Emerald Herald speculation I love
doing it so take off your channel
conspiracy hats and put back on your DLC
speculation hats for a second because
I'm not done talking about the potential
of there being more DLC there's still a
fair bit left in the game files we
haven't seen and from software
intentionally calls the ivory King DLC
the final chapter of the Crown's trilogy
they don't call it the end of
soles - if I was to guess I'd say that
there's more DLC coming although I'm not
100% sure obviously collecting all three
crowns wasn't a conclusion from a law
point of view and even from a gameplay
point of view it wasn't conclusive
either if there was nothing left to
fight why would they give us the power
to resist hollowing you know
and also if Dark Souls 2 ends here what
kind of stage does this set for Dark
Souls 3 considering our main character
in Dark Souls 2 has inherited the power
to exist throughout timelines that would
be a really weird premise to start Dark
Souls 3 on although it could still be
done you know your character could
become the big bad boss or your
character could become a legend or
something like that but yeah even
vendrick's last piece of dialogue seems
to be a clue the rest will follow
it might not happen guys but I got a
feeling the DLC was damn good for the
price as well and if the team hasn't
moved on to blood-borne then I really do
expect more out of them the biggest
question I have if there was more DLC is
how is their timing going to work
considering that there's a release of
blood-borne coming in February that's
the most confusing thing to me it's not
going to be easy to balance these two
syriza's and make sure one doesn't
eclipse the other you know if you enjoy
this video you should check out my
patreon page I have a small community
over there that I'm actually able to
handle and keep in touch with and
they're allowing me to continue doing
what I love so I'm so thankful for that
but the real person I need to thank is
you for watching my videos so thank you
for watching this one let me know if you
had any thoughts on it it's great to get
some discussion going down below
and speaking of discussion my
discussions down in my comments section
are some of the most mature and best
discussions I've seen on YouTube I was
actually looking at my analytics page on
YouTube the other day now this is a page
that shows you statistics and stuff and
over 50% of you are over the age of 18
compared to other channels that's a lot
of you only 8% of you are between the
ages of 13 and 17 and that shows in the
comments trust me most discussions are
actually mature and I reckon I have one
of the best fan bases out there and I'm
being completely serious about that I'm
actually basing it on evidence as
that the most evidence I have is that I
can look at a comment section and not
want to kill myself which is nice it's
really awesome that we can all chat down
there with decent people and hey age is
just a guideline even if you're below
the age of 18
doesn't mean you're immature it just
means you're statistically more likely
to be anyway guys I'll catch you in the
next one please
you